it seems like they made their marriage
work and that he was happy enough that
he didn't want to let that go and then
also had five kids so what you seemed
wanted to go the other way with that of
course but why you say of course because
that's just who I am I guess just why I
like that from the beginning you always
felt like that you didn't always like
being there longing to be a dad or no
you're probably an uncle are you not a
bunch I think so
I think they have some children does
that make me an uncle
I don't I don't think much about that
are you not involved in their nieces and
nephews I don't even know why I'm asking
that you don't even know if you have
the Honeydew
[Music]